do you watch yourself no
never no well i said the show i'm doing
right now is power for force power for
force on stars on stars it's the 50 cent
courtney camp
um
power universe you watch that
i just i've been just finished the first
season and i love joseph sakora honestly
he's one of the best if not the
actor i've ever worked with maybe the
best maybe very close to
wow yeah he's [ __ ] bro i'm telling
you joseph sakura
is one of the most underestimating
actors of our time this guy he's just so
good
another guy michael soccer who's also
broken anyway the elevator i diverse and
to watch these guys
i love it and i want to be and i like to
play in that arena i want it come on
let's just go for it and i love it now
it makes you better doesn't it makes you
it's like when you're playing you know i
play pick up sports like i'll play pick
up hockey and if i'm out there with a
bunch of other old guys like me
you know i'm just i don't
but when
there's great players playing against
you like sometimes the some pros play on
their off season it elevates you it
makes you want to be better it excites
you slightly you know it does it's just
exciting i love them
have you ever missed smallville
[Music]
no really i mean it was a big part of my
life our life
okay i mean you ever feel like watching
an old episode and talking about stuff
you know
no no never well would you would you do
it for me
no would you do it for the fans
[Music]
yeah why not
be fun
join tom welling and michael rosenbaum
every week as they rewind every episode
of smallville and discuss their
experiences with friends fans and
co-stars tockville the ultimate
smallville podcast are you still honest
to god don't lie to me do you get
nervous i get terrified you still get
nervous when yes yes yes yes every time
every time bro not every take but
usually
once once once i'm in once a minute i'm
fine but just that walk from the trailer
to the [ __ ] stage
then get that first line out especially
that first day
oh my god
yeah why is it i don't maybe you want
everybody to go okay he's here for a
reason the director's like yeah tommy's
here he's good everybody's good like
okay now i can stop being so afraid and
you get that and that's wonderful but at
the same time they're just saying that
it's so it's crazy
it's such mind